finally
i freeze myself from gotcha hell oh i
can finally get on with my life
wonder what this is
not again forgive me father
for i have simped
2020 has been a year
of things happening it seems like this
year the world just decided to do a gold
split speed run of setting itself on
fire with a new
exciting record of depressing shits
being set every month but while the
entire world has gone to [ __ ] and we've
been forced to stay inside there has
never been
a better time to just hole up and watch
all the anime that we've wanted to watch
imagine watching out of me in 2020. you
see in between the [ __ ] apocalypse
we've been experiencing we've been given
a beacon of hope this year a single ray
of light in the endless darkness we've
been experiencing
gentlemen i've seen the future
cute anime girls
on youtube youtubers or virtual
youtubers has been a trend that has
absolutely exploded onto our scene this
year a genre comprised of real people
using normally anime themed virtual
avatars to create content online
if you've been following me on various
other platforms this video is probably
the worst kept secret on my channel in
between my slow descent to the rabbit
hole to um
some moment of weaknesses it's kind of
just taken over my schedule
it was something i started to get into
near the beginning of the year and has
since grown to a point i didn't think it
could
this is like the third iteration of the
scripts i've worked on because 2020 has
been such a massive year for v
tubers that by the time i finish the
draft some parts have become irrelevant
and new parts needed to be added
that's how fast the scene has been
evolving this year for those on the
outside it may just seem like another
passing fad but right now it is bigger
than it ever has been before
every week there seems to be a new one
debuting more and more interest has been
expressed over the internet and right
now
seven of the top 10 earnings super chat
users in the world
on youtube are be tubers love them or
hate them they are rising up fast and it
looks like they are here to stay
but what is the appeal of these virtual
girls and why are they becoming so
popular now
well today i thought i'd document my own
journey with youtubers over the past few
months introduce those of you out of the
know why so many seem to be watching
them right now
and speculate what they could mean for
the future of online entertainment
this is your introduction to the 2d
girls that are taking over
welcome to the v tuber rabbit hole
[Music]
before we get into how 2d girls are
slowly taking over our souls we need to
go
back to the beginning to happier more
innocent times before the world was
plunged into chaos yes
that's right we need to go all the way
back to the prehistoric age
of 2016. yeah
it's rewind time
[Music]
the idea of having a virtual avatar
represent a live human playing them is
far
older than what we know modern youtubers
as today which begs the question
who actually was the first v tuber oh i
got it wasn't it like amy yamato that
virtual vlogger that came out way before
the times
nope think again [ __ ] annoying orange
was the first
feature nah you're all wrong
with my bird it was the [ __ ] gorillas
wasn't there whatever your technical
definition of what a v
cheaper is there is undeniably one
person we can thank
for starting this modern be cheaper
scene
he's an artist it's pretty well known
that the godmother of the entire
youtuber scene was
kizna i debuting in november 2016 she
made
massive waves in the anime community and
beyond immediately amassing close to a
million subscribers by the end of 2017
which as someone else in the anime
community who also reached a million
subs at the end of 2007
took me 10 damn years to do
but i'm not a cute anime girl so i'm not
even mad it's impossible to ignore that
the roots of the modern v
tuber stem heavily from the idol culture
in japan and of course
vocaloids in between the pure perfect
image of a human idol and the digitally
generated mascot of hats when they miku
and ko
kiznai was something in between both of
those someone who was clearly more human
than the vocaloid digital pop stars but
still technically a character who
wasn't human instead of a real idol we
had a virtual idol
someone who could combine the best of
both worlds to create something new
when kids and i first debuted i remember
thinking [ __ ]
this is the future how are we meant to
compete with real waifus on the same
platform
we were never meant to compete with cute
anime girls to me something like this
was inevitable
it was only a matter of time before
someone attempted something like this
the only trigger was waiting for the
technology behind it to become feasible
i thought to myself
this was just the start and it was
kagia luna mirai akari siro kiznai
started a boom with a whole new plethora
of youtubers popping up to try and
imitate the success she saw and some of
them did
decently well by march of 2018 there was
something in the realm of over a
thousand virtual youtubers and that
number saw exponential growth over the
coming months hitting 8
000 around 18 months later according to
a japanese virtual youtuber tracking
site
which is a stupidly large number youtube
has created its own massive space in
japan you could argue to the point of
over saturation
but despite this it would kind of just
remain within its own niche
after the initial boom a lot of people
especially outside of asia just kind of
forgot about youtubers for a while we
all knew about kiznai and that vichy was
had become this massive thing
in japan but that was mostly the extent
of our knowledge and many of us
went back to doing what we had always
done watching cute anime girls in anime
instead of watching cute anime girls on
youtube
but eventually that would begin to
change
[Music]
for the most part the popularity and
appeal of youtubers would stay
localized in japan mainly because well
most of them were japanese despite a
loyal fanbase dedicated to translating
videos
no one btuber would get the same kind of
wide recognition as kismet i
and over the years even her popularity
would begin to decline with her parent
company even introducing multiple
personalities in an attempt to increase
the amount of producible content without
limiting
it to one person playing her so you may
be wondering what is the modern v
tuber scene like today well remember
this clip that went semi viral around
our parts back in the day
well imagine if we could just take this
one clip
and make an entire genre around it
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
right now youtubers are in the midst of
a second renaissance and if you've been
hanging around anime twitter or the rest
of the community you may have heard
names like hololive being thrown around
who are right now the group right at the
center of it all so
what is hololive well we can let the
founder of the group himself explain it
is so that was a [ __ ] lie
follow live is the brainchild of
motoraki tanego better known as yago in
the community it's essentially an agency
for v
cheapers but while someone like using
the eye is managed by a single agency
hololive has a whole plethora of
youtubers that operates under the
hololive umbrella
while there are other very successful
agencies like niji sanji that are
operating i'm mainly spotlighting hollow
lives for just how much of an effect
they've been able to have on the vichy
was seen outside of japan
no other agency has come close to seeing
the international reach that they've had
and have really led the boom we've seen
this year
so what's changed since the kisner eye
days well instead of scripted or
pre-recorded content
the youtubers are now far more
associated with live streaming content
and [ __ ] posting there's a lot
a lot of [ __ ] posting
yes jago may have intended to create a v
tuber akb-48 but
what he actually got was closer to a v
tuber ak-47
what i find interesting about how the
modern scene has grown is that it's
almost de-evolved from where it started
kisna-eye completely revolutionized the
concept of using virtual avatars using
full-body tracking and 3d space which
considering the technical knowledge and
initial cost for equipment had a huge
barrier for entry but now most youtubers
can get away with a simple live 2d
avatar superimposed on some basic face
tracking software which pretty much
anyone can do
hell even i've used it before in some of
my previous videos
however despite the more limited
technology this new wave is arguably
just as
if not even more successful and for
those looking from the outside in
it may be confusing to see what exactly
is the appeal of a v-tuber
i never got into kids and i when she
first came out and i've never been into
live streamers either despite the fact
that i respect both as content creators
and the content that they make
so on paper i should have never gotten
swept up in this youtuber renaissance
right but i underestimated my love for
cute anime girls okay
yes i know i have a problem i should
have known better vichy was first
started to appear on my radar earlier in
the year with clips here and there of
these cute anime girls speaking english
and
very occasionally just saying the n-word
but it wouldn't be until a few clips
started to appear on my youtube homepage
that i would truly start to fall into
the hole all it takes is one or two
videos before youtube's algorithm takes
over and gives you an endless flood of
more the ones that got me was matt's
retelling her band-aid story and fabuki
singing her version of
man and it was as i was watching a cute
anime girl singing about
how much she wants to beat up a
pineapple i had this
epiphany i don't know what it was about
these clips that stood out to me
immediately but
if i had to put it into words it was
very reminiscent
of the appeal of old youtube i mean at
the end of the day it was a bunch of
girls [ __ ] about behind an anime
avatar one was just doing this really
really cute song cover
and the other was just telling the story
about how she wore band-aids as a bra
once for school
these weren't some super polished high
production videos they were just some
bare bones avatar doing what smosh did
back in the day
or og story time vloggers and there was
just
something inherently charming about that
and then that was that
once i went v i could never be free on
the outside the anime avatar thing can
just seem like a gimmick but
even without that it's impossible to
deny that many youtubers especially the
ones at hololive
are just very talented at what they do
there are a ridiculous number of
different youtubers with different
personalities and appeal doing all sorts
of different content
some of them are very much acting as a
character and some of them more often
than not slip into their real life
persona but whatever their style all of
them have found their own way to be
really entertaining whether it be [ __ ]
posting a ton
being good at video games or just acting
really
[ __ ] adorable to put it in a way that
any weeb can understand
youtubers are just anime's newest genre
cute girls do live streaming things and
some of you may be thinking
well why would i want to watch a
youtuber over a regular streamer then
why do people get invested in youtubers
when they are just
playing this character and well the
closest analogy i can compare
this to is wrestling okay just hear me
out
wrestling is fascinating to me because
it's something that exists between a
scripted show and a real sport
we all know that wrestling is fake
wrestling fans know that wrestling is
fake and yet they are able to invest
themselves in these events these
characters as if it was a real sport
with real people but there are times
when the line between a wrestler and
real person playing them can get blurry
storyline and characters can sometimes
bleed into the real world that can make
you unsure whether you're watching a
scripted piece of fiction or a real
event unfolding but whatever the case
the fan investment in them is 100
genuine
okay i'm gonna stop pretending that my
wrestling knowledge extends anything
beyond a super eye patch wolf video but
the point i'm trying to make is that i
think v tubers exist in that same
uncanny valley
you know there's a real person behind
this anime avatar you know they are just
playing this character but
who the [ __ ] cares about that it's a
[ __ ] puppy girl playing video games
and it's adorable as [ __ ] okay
that's right youtubers is just wrestling
with waifus jesus i can't wait for that
line to be quoted out of context
the attachment i feel towards a v tuber
is the same i feel towards a fictional
character but i give them the same kind
of respect i would any real person or
just another content creator
and just because they are anime avatars
doesn't make them any less authentic
because
just like wrestling fans your investment
in these people
these characters can create genuine
moments for you or
in other words your feelings for her
are not real they are real to me but
look i can talk all day about the
theoretical appeal of youtubers and not
get through at all because the best way
is just to experience them for yourself
so giggup how does one get into v-tubers
so giggup where do i start with this
rabbit hole what is the watch order give
me the watch order this is the first one
in the series kerone monogatry or
perhaps kiriyukoko's feet stay night
what the [ __ ] is a feet compilation the
only compilation i know from
x videos is a cream pie compilation the
good news is that there's not exactly a
lack of choice and the best thing is
they're all
such good girls it's so hard to choose a
best girl
i mean you got best girl and then also
best girl and best best girl and best
best best girl
and a [ __ ] psychopath
stay home actually now i think about it
most of these girls are [ __ ]
psychopaths aren't they recently hollow
live debut their english talent and for
anyone english speaking that would most
likely be the best gateway into the
world as it gives a good idea of what
it's like watching a v
tuber and overall what's being part of
the hololive experience is all about
there are a total of five girls each
with very
different personalities and appeals so
if you give them all a go there's
probably gonna be one that floats your
boat and while they're still very new
they've already managed to leave a
strong impression you've got a tinder a
death god rapper in modi karaoke who's
actually insanely talented in music and
releasing her own original songs the
comfiest [ __ ] streamer in nino my
innerness whose voice can soothe your
soul a chaotic energetic detective in
amelia watson
a love walker for chicken i mean
majestic
phoenix in kiara and gagura who's so
[ __ ] sweet watching her streams is
like injecting pure glucose into my
[ __ ] veins
despite just debuting they've all
managed to establish themselves very
quickly and
all very talented individuals but out of
all of them gargada probably understands
the internet landscape the best which
shows that she's probably the fastest
growing horror life member right now of
reaching over 500 000 subscribers in
just a few weeks
beyond that we have the established
japanese talent of which there are now
five generations
with dozens of girls all who have their
own law and memes and also have
different relationships with each other
it's going to be impossible to go for
every girl in this video so instead in
no
order or preference here are some
interesting stuff that might catch your
interest if you're a newbie getting
kitty koko is probably one of the most
newbie friendly youtubers and it's not
really a secret that i'm a regular
viewer of her channel and before holler
life english debuted was the closest
thing to a liaison the international
fans had as she's both fluent in english
and japanese a three thousand year old
dragon girl who found
is american born thanks to the way she
moves her hips yes you can even be a 2d
girl but even in anime hips don't lie
that is america's ass she has a show
called asakoko going over the latest
news in holla live but recently she's
also been doing a series where she
reviews english hololive
memes with other japanese members and
not only is this a very fun watch but it
is genuinely interesting to see how
internet humor translates across
different languages and culture
in terms of being a pure content creator
she's not only charismatic but
understands what makes good content and
is able to deliver on it
overall coco is great and she has the
thighs of a greek goddess herself
thigh review kinomori luna has a design
drawn by the aeromanga sensei artist
and for once going against the anime
trope of having a lolly who's secretly 2
000 years old luna's age seems to be
about negative 20.
[Music]
fabuki is [ __ ] adorable and if you
watch only one thing after watching this
video just watch one of the song covers
this is what youtube was invented for
wanna hear someone try to input a
[ __ ] tekken 7 combo via laugh input
will always have a soft spot for me
because it was a lot of her clips that
first pulled me into the hole out of all
the girls she actually seems like the
most normal
it doesn't feel like she's playing a
character she's just a genuinely
charismatic and fun girl who's also a
[ __ ] degenerate seriously just check
out any of the clips if you want an
authentic
genuine stream of a girl just [ __ ] a
balance behind an anime avatar
porsche marine is horny there's corona
she's a dog that's pretty much it now
you may be wondering what's the appeal
of watching an anime dog live streaming
i mean
it's just a cute little doggo playing
video games
like she's a innocent ball of
wholesomeness who can
melt your heart and cure depression like
what's so special about making the
cutest little noises like
and i don't know about this smile that
will make you want to drop everything
and pledge your allegiance to protect it
it's not like i want to head pat her or
anything why would i want a head powder
okay
maybe she deserves the head pad someone
should give her the head pads i'll give
it to her let me just
sit here get up get off me get it get
off me sydney
let me hang that up she just loves the
handbags
[Music]
which how do i begin to describe the
hachima experience
hachima is the [ __ ] chaotic
degenerate energy i didn't know i needed
in my life in my mind she's the waifu
offspring of filthy frank and howtobasic
her content is cursed it's anarchy it's
full-blown [ __ ] degeneracy and it's
absolutely amazing want a waifu who can
cook for you
well why not watch her destroy basic
cooking skills and such classics like
[ __ ] made pasta want a pure perfect
idol
no problem why not listen to some
wholesome vomit asmr as she accidentally
pukes on stream doing the spicy noodle
challenge
what's the matter out in the chat type
out kawaii oh
you think the fans are the degenerates
here don't worry she was the one who
asked viewers to send in their feet
videos so she could review them herself
in one of the most
cursed streams ever made i don't really
have a point of reference to pinpoint
the kind of entertainment this content
is
like there's even a stream where she's
reacting to her own leads that artists
drew for her
i am watching a [ __ ] anime girl
reviewing her own loot is this not the
peak of internet content
why am i even trying how can anyone
compete with this
and this is part of the reason why i got
into youtubers from purely a content
perspective
some of the stuff these girls are doing
is genuinely interesting and
entertaining content that wouldn't be as
fun if it was a scripted anime or a
regular irl streamer it's because they
exist in the space between anime
character and real person that they can
explore
original ideas or get away with things
that other people can't who exists
in the same space and that's why this is
something i legitimately believe
falls into its own genre of
entertainment like i didn't wake up
thinking that watching this anime girl
die inside as she sees this yoshi
plushie getting violated by
foot would be so entertaining but it is
and i have no idea why and i'm gonna
stop it there even though i just barely
scratched the surface but
i get it now i get why youtube has
become such a huge trend in japan all
this time idle culture or not and with
their explosive growth this year
it makes me think what this could
possibly mean for the future of online
content
[Laughter]
hololive's recent english talent debut
was an event that just dominated all of
the discussions in our community for a
while ironically more than i've seen for
any of the anime that have aired this
year so far the buzz created on social
media was staggering
youtubers seem to be inescapable and if
you think about it it kind of makes
sense the reason we call it a rabbit
hole is because with the amount of
content being generated
even just by hololive alone it is
literally impossible to consume it all
you may fall in deeper and deeper but
you can never reach the bottom and all
this content isn't even centralized
under one channel you've got the
hololive channel the individual hot
alive talents channel
niji sanji independent youtubers dozens
and dozens of individual highlights
channels
all interlinked within youtube's
algorithm creating this perfect storm
the v tube of rabbit hole was
practically designed to take over
youtube and i don't see it going away
i think the big turning point for me was
seeing the discussion around vichy was
reached
way past the community who'd usually
watch it pokeyman came out with a
youtuber avatar along with many other
notable streamers looking to follow suit
soon
and many many more are either about to
debut or have expressed interest in
wanting to become one themselves
because trends aside money speaks and
the message
is loud and clear it was revealed that
seven of the top 10 earnings super chat
users in the world
were youtubers and at the top was coco
earning around 810
000 since debuting late last year
averaging
way over 100k per month that
is through donations alone not including
other revenue streams which
be right back i'm just going to retire
so it can become a cute anime girl no
matter how you look at it these are
insane
numbers and judging by the initial stats
of the english speaking term 2 that's a
trend that seems to be continuing
internationally too i mean just look at
how fast this super chat is going
there are few things in the world that
can transcend the language barrier
money laughter compassion
and now [ __ ] simps
it's really no wonder why there's so
much attention and interest which is why
even if this hype dies down over time
i don't think it's just going to be a
passing fad i think we've seen the birth
of another subculture within our
community i've focused a lot on hollow
life on their rise but i didn't even
touch on the independent victory was
seen
because really the first youtuber who've
already broken to the english speaking
scene was probably project melody
earlier this year she debuted earlier
this year as the first virtual cam girl
breaking all kinds of viewership records
and has cinch established herself as an
all-around vicious live streamer and has
really led the way for other independent
content creators on twitch and other
live streaming platforms
this year really has been the perfect
storm that has taught us that
2d was the future all along if 2020 has
taught me anything it's that weebs are
far too willing to drop cash when it
comes to cute anime girls like
i don't know if we just come with
something hardwired into a [ __ ] brain
that just gives us this uncontrollable
reflex
to throw a bunch of money whenever we
see 2d anime tiddy
or you know some beautiful [ __ ]
anime thoughts i don't know maybe that's
just me is simping
v tubers tax deductible
are you [ __ ] serious but you know
what i will say that watching youtubers
has at least given me
something tangible or at least helped me
work towards something tangible
like when i was getting into gacha games
i'm sure a lot of people saw that video
and thought
wow this looks like a dangerous
addiction i mean this is just basically
a waifu casino right
and look what i'll say to that is if i'm
gonna have a gambling addiction
at least i can have a gambling addiction
i can jack off to but watching v
tubers without subtitles has
legitimately improved my japanese
listening skills as someone who's trying
to learn the language
far more than years of watching anime
has done because you're forced to really
pay attention to what they say
so unlike gacha games this has actually
helped me in a real life skill
basically what i'm trying to say is if
i'm gonna have a japanese learning
resource
at least i can have a japanese learning
resource like 2020 has been the year of
youtubers
and it looks like it's gonna stick
around so while you're here why try to
fight it
if there's ever been a time to dip your
toes into something new why not join us
in the rabbit hole and welcome our new
2d overlords because you know i may have
played it up as a joke but
please don't go simp crazy guys i'm not
really some waifu addict who can't stop
dropping cash on cute anime girls
v cheapers are great and i love them but
this
isn't really an addiction it's fine guys
i can quit anytime i like
[Music]
joe augustine ivido we bologist ricky
zob mondo and everyone else my patreon
for helping to support me for this month
oh and just a quick note if this video
has gotten you interested in getting
into the youtube rabbit hole
remember guys these are their own
content creators with their own rules
for their own streams
look i just want to give them respect
and the last thing i want to do is have
my name spammed or anything spammed on
any of youtubers i've mentioned in this
video i'm just here to promote good
content
and like everyone else i respect them as
creators and i just want them to keep
doing what they're doing
anyway though that's it from me i hope
to see all of you
in the rabbit hole by next week i've
been giggup and i will see you
all next time rip anime content in 2020